foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear it's my movie review series
so I saw this movie bug back when it was
released in theaters it was in 2007 now
the movie actually debuted at can in uh
2006 but obviously I didn't see it till
later on I think Lionsgate bought it and
they released it in theaters so I saw it
back then and when I first saw it it
really kind of knocked my socks off so
for a long time I'd actually been
wanting to revisit it for this movie
review series and so I was very excited
to see that HBO Max had added it I think
it might be on Hulu as well but I
watched it on HBO Max now uh so yeah so
I finally got around to it now it's not
exactly a horror movie it I feel like it
usually gets classified as a horror
movie or maybe as a psychological
Thriller both of those things are
accurate but
I don't know this is just kind of one of
those movies that's sort of like a genre
defying I guess and I tend to really
like those not always obviously but I
tend to really like movies that kind of
like play around with genre like that or
where you can't really put it into a
definitive genre so this movie was
directed by William friedkin uh who
directed The Exorcist duh among many
other things and is based on an
award-winning stage play by Tracy Letts
uh so you can tell it's based on a stage
play but that's not a ding against it at
all because this is like amazing it's
really kind of this intensely
claustrophobic like character study and
it's essentially like a descent into
madness I guess or specifically how one
person's Madness can infect someone else
under the right or the wrong uh
circumstances
so the whole thing is set in pretty much
just a single grungy motel room I think
there's a couple other shots like one in
a bar and stuff like that but it's
pretty much all set in this one motel
room and features only a handful of
characters like two main ones and a
couple of other kind of outside ones
well actually like three other outside
ones
um but I will say that this movie really
kind of benefits from this just
simmering atmosphere of dread that it
has like from the very very beginning
and the really kind of like fearlessness
of the two lead actors I mean this is an
all-in performance
um both of them should have got Oscar uh
consideration neither of them did sadly
I think Ashley Judd wanna uh got a
Saturn award for it or a nomination or
something but other than that nothing
and that's really really a shame because
you don't usually see actors just like I
said just go all in for it and go For
Broke like this and it's really really
something to see so at the beginning of
the movie there's it opens with this
really phenomenal shot of this isolated
roadside Motel it's called The Rustic
Motel it's obviously seen much better
days uh and it's off this real lonely
Highway somewhere in BFE Oklahoma
someplace so the camera it's like it's
kind of like watching this sad little
place from really really far off so not
only only can you see how just utterly
out in the middle of [ __ ] know where
it is but it also kind of gives you the
sense that larger forces are watching
which ties very much in with the whole
theme of the of the movie and then like
it kind of slowly closes in there's like
nothing around every now and then like a
car goes by and it's just like this
little place in the middle of nowhere
almost it's like almost like it's on a
planet like all of its own so then as we
close in uh we meet one of our
protagonists Agnes uh or Aggie who's
played by Ashley Judd now before we
really even know anything about her I
mean she's just kind of standing outside
her room like smoking or whatever
um but you can tell a few things
you can tell that she lives alone in
this rundown dump of a motel that she's
lived there for a little while you can
tell that she's very desperately lonely
and it's possible that she's afraid of
something or someone or hiding from
something or someone like the phone in
her room keeps ringing and she seems
like kind of freaked out about like
reluctant to answer and then when she
does answer it there's nobody there on
the other end of the line she says she
can just hear breathing but she can't
hear like nobody says anything
um she suspects that it's someone named
Jerry who you're assuming is an ex and
she's clearly done with his [ __ ] I
mean she's basically like I have a gun
all this other kind of stuff but he
never says anything if indeed that's who
it is so Agnes works at this kind of
like Honky Tonk uh lesbian bar which is
like at the back end to be on somewhere
and her best friend is another woman who
works there who's like a cocktail
waitress or something like that named RC
now one night after work RC comes to the
motel room to hang out have a little bit
of a party she's going to another party
later so it's a little bit of pre-gaming
kind of situation
so she brings some booze and also she
brings this mysterious stranger that was
in the bar earlier
uh this is a somewhat reticent Man by
the name of Peter now he's actually
played by Michael Shannon who uh
actually reprises his role he was in the
stage version of this and when William
friedkin because William friedkin I
think in Tracy let's collaborated on
another movie I think it was called
Killer Joe like uh I think that freaking
I mean did another adaptation and one of
Tracy Tracy left his place but William
friedkin was like insistent because I
think the pro the production company was
like well we need somebody with more
name recognition than Michael Shannon
I'm like y'all guys need to be slapped
because Michael Shannon is awesome but
um but William friedkin insisted he's
like he's the one that did the part you
know on the stage and I really want him
to be in this movie so they got him to
be in this movie and to the movies like
uh to great benefit so
the two women are in there they're kind
of drinking shooting the [ __ ] like
snorting coke what to do and what you do
and Peter's just kind of like watching
them he's kind of on the on the fringes
or whatever he's kind of bemused I guess
he doesn't really seem to want to
intrude on their fun he seems very um
very awkward a little bit anti-social
but not like in a scary way necessarily
like he very awkwardly like tells Agnes
that she's beautiful and he doesn't like
seem threatening or creepy or anything
like that he just seems like a little
bit like odd or like he doesn't really
have
um any social graces you know what I
mean or he's like not really used to
talking to people now Agnes uh for her
part seems just as weirded out by
receiving compliments as Peter is
obviously is at giving them
um it's pretty clear that whatever her
past might be uh that somebody has
probably done a number on her self-worth
over the years like she doesn't really
think she's worth anything or something
like that you really kind of get that
vibe from her so as it happens RC gets
called away to deal with some kind of
Family Matter that's going on and Peter
says that he'll leave too but Agnes kind
of like reconsiders and she's like oh
why don't you stay for one more drink
she's kind of like intrigued by him like
I said he's very reserved he's very
mysterious but he doesn't
I mean he seems a little bit scary but
not so scary that you'd be like oh my
God this guy's gonna kill me or anything
like that like I don't know it's kind of
hard to explain
so now he tells her at some point he's
like he's not really after sex he's not
he's he says he's not interested in it
and she asks if he's gay and he's like
no I'm just like not anything really
like he's not like he's asexual like
that's what they would say today but
like I guess they didn't really this
came out in 2006 so I don't think that
term was in common use back then
but that's probably what he would say
nowadays
um but he's basically like I'm just
lonely you're lonely um you know I just
wouldn't mind a friend or like somebody
to talk to
now she finds out that he doesn't really
have a place to stay
um so she's like well you know you can
sleep on the couch in here it's fine and
so he's you know very appreciative of
that very gentlemanly and all of that
uh there's also a little bit of a thing
that happens which is a little bit of
foreshadowing
uh Peter hears something in the room
that sounds like a cricket chirping and
it might very well be a cricket chirping
uh Agnes doesn't hear it at first but
then she's like oh yeah yeah I hear what
you're talking about so they search all
over and she's like oh don't kill it
they're good luck or whatever but they
can't find this supposed Cricket
anywhere uh but then Agnes seems to like
narrow it down to the smoke detector and
she's like oh it must be making that
sound because the battery's dead or
whatever and Peter's like well maybe you
should just take that out of here
because that has like some kind of
chemical in it that like [ __ ] with your
mind or is bad for you or something like
that and she's like okay whatever so he
kind of smashes it and throws it away so
the next morning Agnes wakes up and
someone's in the bathroom in the shower
now she assumes that it's Peter as you
would but then her ex-husband Jerry
who's actually played by Harry Connick
Jr looking kind of buff come sleazing
out the bathroom now he's apparently
been released early from prison I think
he's been there he said for like the
past two years I think you find out
later that it was armed robbery maybe
something like that and uh Agnes is
extremely not excited to see him uh you
know he's like hey didn't you miss me
she's like I can't say that I did no you
know
I mean uh now but he acts all like uh as
though they were just on a break or
something and he's like oh didn't you
get my letter and it's like she's like
[ __ ] that I didn't get you know I didn't
even know you were getting out or
whatever but he kind of just acts like
he's just gonna move right back in and
pick up where they left off and she's
like nah bro that's not gonna happen so
basically he just is acting like she's
not even saying anything and then
finally she straight up tells look I
hate you and you need to get the [ __ ]
out of here and so he uh not
surprisingly punches her in the face and
then does the whole abuser dance of look
what you made me do you [ __ ] blah blah
now shortly after this happens this
confrontation Peter comes back like he's
gone to the store like to get them some
coffee and muffins or whatever and Jerry
of course acts like an [ __ ] to him
like making fun of the way that he talks
and all this other kind of stuff and
then um you know he takes off he says oh
I have some business to take care of
down south I'm assuming it's some kind
of criminal deal or whatever uh for a
week or two but then I'll be coming back
in here you want to have to move
anything around I don't have that much
stuff you know I mean like he's just
gonna like Waltz in there and move back
in she's like yeah great whatever the
[ __ ] so after he leaves
Agnes tells Peter she's like yeah I was
married to him for a long time and then
I'm still afraid of him I'm sure he's
like yeah rightfully so
um and then she also says after a while
she didn't really want to talk about it
but you know he kind of like asks her
about it uh she's like yeah we had a son
named Lloyd who uh about a decade ago
like uh her and her son were in a
grocery store she turned around to get
something and she turned around and he
was gone so he was obviously like ran
off or was abducted or whatever and she
looked for him for years and years but
they never could find any uh trace of
him and she's basically like well you
know I guess I kind of stopped looking
for him after a while she's like in my
dreams I still look for him but like I'm
just pretty sure that he's gone
so you can see now like why she's sort
of like ended up in this place that
she's at in her life she had this this
abusive ex-husband her son disappeared
and she can't really deal with that
um so she's very very damaged I mean
she's I don't know if I'd call her a
drunk but she does like drink a lot um
she does a lot of Like Cocaine crack and
all this other kind of stuff
um she just kind of lives this dead end
existence like working in the bar you
know and just living in this like shitty
motel room so since Agnes and Peter are
both these kind of like lost souls I
guess they start to develop something of
a romantic connection I guess I don't I
hesitate to use that word because it's
not exactly what happens but I mean they
do have sex and stuff but I don't know
it's like something else going on I mean
this initially seems nice because you're
like oh you know now they both have
somebody and they were lonely before but
uh you kind of slowly start to realize
that Peter is severely tragically
mentally ill
so it starts with kind of like standard
low-level conspiracy theory stuff like
you know the thing about the smoke
detector having like weird chemicals in
it
um you know there's machines that
control everyone's thoughts
um you know and they're happy when you
find out about them because they know
there's nothing you can do about it
um and then he starts seeing bugs he
starts seeing like um he calls them
aphids I guess but he first sees them in
the beds and he says they're like biting
him and so he's like it's right there
it's right there and she's like look I
don't see anything
um but then like the more he insists
that it's there she's like oh yeah maybe
I do see he's just like it's just really
small it's really small
so there's that kind of stuff it just
kind of starts out with that which again
red flag but you know she's lonely she's
damaged she's just kind of like well
he's just got a couple little quirks no
big deal yeah we'll see how that goes uh
but so as The Story Goes On uh his
paranoia drastically escalates he starts
believing that the bugs are essentially
like infesting his blood and like eating
him from the inside he starts like
cutting like trying to dig them out like
from under his skin
um and he gets a microscope from
somewhere and he's so he's kind of like
digging stuff out and then like looking
at him under the microscope and he can
supposedly like see them even though
we're pretty sure there's really nothing
there
um he's looking at pretty much
everything like underneath the
microscope because he's starting to
become convinced that everything in the
room now is covered with these bugs you
know what I mean which he almost kind of
like he talks about them like
interchangeably as though they're like
organic but also if they're kind of like
genetically engineered like they're
watching them and stuff like that he
also starts to believe at least
initially
that the bugs were purposely implanted
in him by the army so we find out that
he was actually in the Army for a while
but he's gone AWOL uh he admits because
he became convinced that him and some of
the other other soldiers he says like
Timothy McVeigh were being experimented
on during the Gulf War like they were
injecting them with these like mind
control uh drugs or bugs or whatever the
[ __ ] so we skip ahead a couple of weeks
to the time of Jerry's return
and when he comes back uh things have
certainly changed in the old motel room
since the last time he dropped by uh the
whole place is now just festooned with
no pest strips uh and all of the walls
and Furniture like pretty much
everything in there is completely
covered with aluminum foil
um all the better to keep the bugs from
transmitting their thought control waves
it also becomes evident that in this
two-week period that Jerry was gone that
Agnes you know being as depressed as she
was as vulnerable as terrified of
Abandonment she really got scared she
didn't want Peter to leave her like I
said she has really bad abandonment
issues uh probably stemming from the kit
from the uh Abduction of her son
she's actually become completely
consumed by Peter's delusions as well so
the pair of them so she is all in now
like she believes in the bugs she
started like digging stuff out of her
skin she's like slapping herself around
like oh my God they're all over me and
blah blah all of that kind of stuff she
totally believes the same [ __ ] that he
believes because she's like standing by
her man you know what I mean so the pair
of them have like isolated themselves
from the outside world in this motel
room that's now covered with like you
know bug zapper lights and it's just all
covered with tinfoil it looks crazy like
it looks like really really creepy like
actually like the third Act of the film
like that takes place just in the motel
room and it's all like covered with tin
foil with these creepy like bug zapper
lights is actually like really effective
I really like like the way they shot it
so yeah basically so the two of them
have been like feeding off of each
other's like and encouraging each
other's like intensifying derangement
right so it uh it all ends up I don't
want to spoil too much about it but it
all ends up in some pretty extreme
places uh there's some you know DIY
Dentistry there's some murder there's
some self-immolation uh that kind of
stuff
but the fascinating thing about the
movie to me
is that the story actually does leave a
tiny bit of room for doubt to kind of
creep in on the part of the viewer like
if this is all in their heads you know
the film seems to be whispering in your
ear then who was it that was making all
those mysterious phone calls at the
beginning like she thought it was Jerry
but he's like nah I never called you or
anything like that who the [ __ ] else
would be calling her because nobody else
knew that she lived there like what
exactly is the deal with these
helicopters that seem to be buzzing the
motel from time to time who exactly is
this Dr sweet fellow that shows up and
says he's from the Army and he's like oh
you know Peter like was supposed to
escaped from the mental hospital and
it's like you know all this other kind
of stuff and he said some weird [ __ ] but
then like he comes in and he kind of
like helps himself to Agnes his drugs
which seems like a weird thing for a
doctor to be doing and somehow seems to
know about her missing son as well so
it's almost kind of like I'm not really
sure if he's trying to like play into
their delusion like to get them to do
what he wants so he can take them into
custody or what but it's like really
really weird so it's kind of left
somewhat ambiguous uh as to how many of
the how many of the events of the film
like actually occurred like as we see
them or how many of them were actually
just completely imagined by Peter and
Agnes because there's a couple scenes at
the end that suggest that maybe things
didn't happen the way we saw them happen
you know what I mean that it was all
kind of like in their perception so this
was actually like a great aspect of the
story because it puts the viewer in a
similar position to the characters and
kind of demonstrates how easy it can be
to get sucked into these completely
Bonkers conspiracy theories like if all
the circumstances align like if you're
already kind of like primed to believe
that kind of stuff now the play uh even
though the movie came out like I said in
2006 the play was actually written in
1996 uh and I'm not really sure if this
was maybe set in 1996 I'm kind of
imagining it probably is
um so that was only a few years after to
the Gulf War obviously and so this one
is very kind of like steeped in uh that
era's political propaganda and like the
Gulf War syndrome that a lot of the
returning veterans reported but even
though it's kind of you know it's kind
of coming from that era it's focus on
being drawn down these conspiratorial
rabbit holes like to the detriment of
your own sanity is really as relevant if
not more relevant like today than it was
back then I mean Peter's character in
this is tragic you know not just because
he suffers from obviously from paranoid
schizophrenia but because some of the
historical precedence that he uh comes
up with like brings up to back up his
more outlandish assertions some of those
are true like the Tuskegee syphilis
experience MK Ultra like all that kind
of stuff that [ __ ] is true so it's
pretty easy to see how someone whose
mental health is not the best
um could kind of like consider that the
truth of like a couple of these
nefarious theories to be indicative of
this larger thing that like all of them
are true and you know extrapolating from
that um that I myself like that his
character plays a central role in this
like kind of massive web of
interconnected evils you know what I
mean and kind of by the same token Agnes
is tragic because really all she wanted
was a friend I mean she was like I said
she was lonely she had abandonment
issues she was kind of like at a bad
place in her life she just wanted
somebody that would just be there for
her that would listen to her that
wouldn't really ask for anything from
her in return which initially he seemed
to be doing that so because of her own
past you know she can't deal with being
alone and she even says something to
this effect in the film and it's like
being with someone who you know just
talks about bugs all the time or who
eventually like Yanks his own teeth out
because he thinks that there's egg sacks
like and plates it in there uh then
that's better than not having anybody at
all so you can see like what a problem
she's having in there and plus too like
it's much easier to deal
with a rootless unhappy life a life in
which your child disappeared when you
turned your back and you have no idea
where they went then there seemed like
no Rhyme or Reason it's easier to deal
with that if you start to believe that
larger Force forces are in control even
if those forces are malevolent which
like I said that's kind of like a pretty
you know that's how a lot of people get
sucked out into conspiracy theories
because you know if your life's kind of
shitty and all of these shitty random
things seem to have be happening to you
you would rather have somebody in
control even if that somebody hated your
hated you you know what I mean so I kind
of see how she fell into this kind of
stuff so I mean if you're really into
kind of disturbing
psychological dramas like I said I don't
know if it's overtly a horror movie but
it definitely has horror elements to it
and there is like some gore and like
some pretty like [ __ ] up like I said
pulling their own teeth out somebody
gets stabbed pretty horribly like that
kind of stuff but if you're into those
kind of movies that just have a real
intense focus on a couple of characters
then I think bug is like just a really
underseen gem you really need to jump
right on it I really don't feel like a
lot of people talk about it anymore and
I think it's really really good and
that's really a shame that you know more
people should probably see it I mean
Michael Shannon and Ashley Judd are
incredible in it
um both of them like I said they
completely commit
to the insanity in this and like the
scenes toward the end of just their
wildly unspooling rationality uh they're
pretty breathtaking and pretty like
horrifying to behold I have to say now
if you like more traditional horror then
you know you probably won't dig it you
might think it's too slow or too much
like a drama or something like that but
I mean for everybody else this and not
just even horror fans like this is
really like an acting tour de force and
it's a really really good very pointed
examination of sort of like
deteriorating sanity and also how one
person's Madness can infect another
person and like how that could happen
like in a real world scenario so it's a
really really good movie in that regard
and I totally think more people should
see it because like I said it's a shame
that more people don't talk about it and
like I said it's William friedkin so
you'd think that more people would be
into it but I guess not so I'm glad that
I finally got to re-watch it and that I
got to talk about it with you guys so if
you guys have seen it what did you think
about a bug from two thousand 6 2007 let
me know in the comments and that will do
it for this flickers of fear I will see
you guys again on the next one bye